that siege was criminal behavior that we
the fbi view as domestic terrorism
social media serves as a gathering place
for many of these domestic terrorists we
are facing a more dangerous period than
we faced in oklahoma city january 6
was not an isolated event the problem of
domestic terrorism
has been metastasizing across the
country for a long time now and it's not
going away anytime soon
[Music]
more than two months after rioters
stormed the capital washington dc is
still occupied by national guard troops
the police say they want to make the
fencing that surrounds the capitol
building permanent
the government responded to january 6th
by turning the capital into like a green
zone or like a war zone
that you would find in a war-torn
country
political scientist max abrams who
studies global terrorism says the u.s
government's response is
disproportionate to the actual threat
this was one of those situations where
the government
swung like a pendulum from doing too
little
to doing too much they're clearly
overwhelmed and unprepared for this
onslaught and so the government
responded by putting in place something
like
25 000 national guards
in caging up the capital and that would
be
appropriate not to deter
next timothy mcveigh but to deter
something like isis storming baghdad
and luckily that's not the kind of
threat environment that we're dealing
with
in the united states abrams worries that
the war on terror started by the bush
administration after 9 11
which included detaining suspects
without due process torture
mass surveillance and counterproductive
military action
is coming to the home front the target
white supremacists and anti-government
militia groups
our response to 911 and this isn't
stressed enough
was actually deeply counterproductive
against the kinds of terrorists that we
were
combating americans can do much better
we don't need to use
a faulty model and apply it to
the very real terrorism problem that we
have at home
instead of toppling dictators the
tactics of this new domestic
war on extremism have so far been
limited to bullying social media
companies
into evicting influential voices from
their platforms such as donald trump
fbi director christopher wray wants the
government to consider repealing section
230 of the communications decency act
to make it even easier to hold tech
platforms liable for content that the
government says
incites violence while the immunity
under section 230 has obviously helped
the evolution of the social media
industry it's also allowed it to avoid
a lot of the burdens and risks that
other brick and mortar companies have
had to face
since the mid-1990s fbi directors have
been citing international terrorism as a
reason to consider preventing the use of
end-to-end encryption rey is now making
the same arguments
citing domestic extremists we are
concerned
about end to end encryption especially
default end-to-end encryption
in connection with a lot of these
platforms in his book rules for rebels
abrams argues that the foreign war on
terror created power vacuums that made
the world
increasingly dangerous such as when
saddam hussein was replaced by al qaeda
in iraq
or when u.s intervention in syria helped
the jihadist group al-nusra foment power
abram says we're in danger of repeating
the same dynamic
in this new war on terror removing
somebody like donald trump from twitter
that might seem like a great idea to
some people
until they realize that actually
donald trump isn't the absolute worst
leader that could possibly bubble up
and in all likelihood the replacements
are going to be even more extreme
we see a similar phenomenon with people
moving from more mainstream
social media platforms like twitter to
ones that have a higher concentration
of right-wing extremists like parlor or
even apps with sort of end-to-end
encryption
where nobody could surveil them
the biden team are now moving in
laser-like fashion to try to uncover as
much they can
about what looks very similar to
insurgency movements that we've seen
overseas and it brings together an
unholy alliance frequently of religious
extremists authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
even libertarians abrams argues that the
perverse effect of lumping such
disparate groups together
is to push otherwise reasonable actors
towards the extremes
i think that these different issues need
to be
unpacked and mainstream media
can't simply say that everyone on the
right including those
who are more in favor of limited
government
and sympathetic to some libertarian
views are
um crazy and believe in pedophile rings
at pizza parlors
there's a massive difference there and i
think that mainstream media and the
government
are trying to weaponize some of the
rightful fear that has come out of
january 6
in order to score a political advantage
and marginalize those on the right
including those
who have quite reasonable views and
frankly many people on the right
continue to do so it was not some sort
of spontaneous
decision by a bunch of quote protesters
to go up to capitol hill
and storm capitol hill this was all
planned out
there's this perverse phenomenon
where terrorism commentators and pundits
um broadcast you know ubiquitously by
the media
they make it seem as if you know
terrorists um are
are just so brilliant and strategic and
effective there was a significant uh
coordination with this attack this was a
planned assault as if going after a
castle
january 6 in some ways was a galvanizing
moment a moment
where some of these extremist groups saw
what was in the realm of the possible
but in fact we often see the exact
opposite
terrorism very often has a
backlash against the very organization
that perpetrates it and we're already
seeing some of that
in terms of participants on january 6th
some of these groups on the far right
now they don't look nearly as attractive
for members for one it's become a
national embarrassment
to be part of these groups the
government
is all over them it's become much more
dangerous
to be in them the domestic terrorism
prevention act which passed the house
back in september would create new
federal law enforcement units
focused solely on domestic terrorism
some politicians and law enforcement
officials have said congress should go
further
under u.s law there is no list
of domestic terrorism organizations the
same way there is for foreign terrorist
organizations well
i don't know if we should have one or
not but i think it's time to think about
it
illiberalism begets more
terrorism one of the telltale signs of
an e-liberal government is when it makes
no distinction between
what it deems as political extremists
and tactical extremists
one of abram's biggest worries is that
in the same way the war on terror that
swept up many innocent muslims spurred
even greater radicalization
a heavy-handed crackdown lumping the
extreme beliefs of some on the right
together with the extreme tactics of
would-be terrorists will ultimately
backfire i'm really worried frankly
about timothy mcveigh 2.0 and i think
that the government
needs to do everything possible not to
create one but i'm not confident that
the government actually
is doing that we should absolutely throw
the book at people
who use terrorism especially against
american civilians what i worry however
is that there is going to be slippage
we cannot crack down on people
just because we don't like their
ideology because
otherwise the government is going to
turn into the thought police
and that is going to spawn the next
generation of terrorists
you